first off let's just get your view of i
was gone right so i came back i came
down the mountain and they're like yo
you russia invaded you crazy yeah yeah
i'm like oh [ __ ] i had no idea like my
phone was off i'm like alright cool uh
let's talk about that first so what is
going on when it comes to the us's role
in this from a financial perspective
right when it comes to jerome powell
everything that's happening in the
market like how should people think
about the us's role in what's happening
in russia and ukraine yeah so the us is
definitely asserting its dominance in
terms of you know being the the global
reserve currency and you know kind of
the world's largest military and kind of
pressing their thumb on top of you know
a couple really key organizations if you
think about nato you think about swift
which is the kind of bank messaging
platform that everyone trades and sells
finance with
and so you know kind of being the kind
of lead dog there you know they can put
that influence over the whole world and
say hey look we're effectively going to
iron curtain put iron curtain around
russia the russian economy russian
oligarchs you know putin himself in
terms of his assets and making it very
difficult make it very painful uh for
them to continue what they're doing
obviously putin is is pretty uh pretty
resolute in um in his game plan here but
the reality is the russian economy is
going to suffer tremendously as a
function of this if it's not already
suffering and how much of a role does
that play do you do you believe right
you're not a war strategist by any means
i don't believe uh but when it comes to
the financial implications right i think
part of this is like let's call some
harm without dropping troops off and
starting to go to war ourselves from a
financial perspective how does this play
out does does russia renege on this
pretty quickly and say hey look this is
much worse than we expected we weren't
able to move as quickly as we thought we
could from a military perspective our
citizens are really hurting financially
now we're cut off from the world just
talk me through kind of how you see that
playing out yeah so there's a lot it's a
loaded question i'll do my best to kind
of summarize the different aspects of it
but you know so let's start by saying
putin is a psychopath that's pretty
clear i don't mean that like as a joke i
mean like if you look at any sort of
like studies like psychopathy like he
very much checks all the boxes i know a
few people who check all those boxes
anyway so um you could say john's name
definitely
not john
anyway so my point is you know he poon's
not going to feel any remorse no matter
how bad it gets for the russian economy
or the russian people so you know his
military objectives are his primary
objective right and you know kind of
showing that force and so we have to
carry on okay if this continues and
these guys continue to go it's very
likely that the ukraine eventually loses
whatever you know resistance that
they're putting up you know just a
matter of time not a matter of if um and
so in that regard you know as long as
you know russia is occupying ukraine
which could be indefinitely right
they're not particularly popular in
ukraine it's not like they're liberating
a bunch of russians they're actually
pissing off a bunch of ukrainians and so
as long as they're occupying ukraine
you could expect to have russia sort of
cut off from global financial markets
for an extended period of time and so
what does that do you think about the
second and third order effects right you
know you've already seen the price
action in bitcoin was that yesterday or
two days ago where stocks were down and
bitcoin was up a tremendous amount um
you know you're going to see you know
assets like that become sources of of of
liquidity for for you know russians
both citizens and and people who are
politically connected to putin and then
there's also the third order effect of
you know kicking rush out of these
indices you know kicking russia out of
you know basically the global economy
you know really sort of kind of
re-jiggers the entire puzzle if you will
in terms of the weightings for other
countries and indices the you know the
waitings for other countries in terms of
the supplies of good commodities and
goods you know so it kind of puts a lot
of
you know costly friction on top of the
global economy on top of global
financial markets at a very kind of
awkward time right and how do you think
uh so there's been a lot that's
happening obviously from from companies
products all this stuff kind of moving
out and removing themselves from
circulation in russia saying we're not
going to sell good services there we're
not gonna do those things but when it
comes to the us dollar specifically
right as the global reserve currency of
the world
how does this work in russia if they
actually get cut off yeah i mean so
you can they're effectively cut off now
right like it's it's you know they're
not mo all russia's major banks i think
with maybe the loan exception of one
bank or something like that are
effectively cut off from swift so that
means i mean their their assets are
frozen
and so if they try to you know you know
if they
i mean they're
they're they're bankrupt there's no
other way to describe it i mean you know
if you can't meet your liquidity your
daily financing needs particularly as a
bank obviously in a fraction reserve
banking system you're you're bankrupt so
that's an issue obviously you're going
to see runs on russian banks but
it doesn't really matter like what
there's no like what the what what even
is a russian bank if it's cut off from
swift what even is a bank if it's cut
off from swift right so like i think you
know this is this is the key takeaway
it's like they can inflict a tremendous
amount of force upon russia like the
western society western world us nato
all those societies without ever
actually you know firing a gun or
shooting a missile and i think that's
exactly what's going to happen we're
early in this process i mean as long as
russia remains cut off from global
dollar financing and is not having that
materially replaced because it's not
clear that china president xi is really
on board with what's happening right now
and as long as china's not really
offsetting that to a tremendous degree
the russian economy is going to shrink
and continue to shrink and shrink and
shrink and shrink and is this something
where you think that they'll eventually
turn to a digital asset like bitcoin or
you think that they'll uh eventually try
to make their own currency digitally or
something else like that yeah so they
have their own um
version of swift right russia started
working on that a few years ago um yeah
it's it's the russian version of swift
so you can imagine it's not exactly what
you want i mean it's not the same thing
yeah exactly you know you have like the
iphone that's made in taiwan and then
there's a knockoff iphone made in russia
and i'm guessing it's a little bit worse
uh touchscreen doesn't work
and so that's exactly what's happening
right like there's you know they're i
want to say that something like 400 or
something financial institutions that
are on that but none of the major ones
none of the the ones you you need to do
business with if you're trying to do
global international markets i mean
russia was the world's 11th largest
economy before they started yeah so this
is a major you know it's a major blow to
the global economy but it's not as big
of a deal to the global economy to lose
russia as it is for russia to lose the
global economy now
i say that to say this like clearly
there's an uh
an issue here with respect to energy
prices you know one analysis i was doing
i see your brothers and charts i'm not
sure if you guys have them or not but um
when you look at energy price spikes you
know historically you know and how we
sort of how i measure energy price
spikes is sort of you can look at the
the speed of the change in price right
like um and so kind of like the the
class the what since the line up west
with the with having an impact on the
economy in terms of perpetuating
recessions or perpetuating big drawdowns
in the equity market um any time you
look at it to energy price spike over
you know 100 percent from a two-year
basis like so you know you tend to get
some economic slowdown or recession or
big drawdown in the equity market and
we're already over that but more
importantly we're about to uh hit the
two-year anniversary of the negative
energy price for march of 2020 right and
so not only are we going to be like up
you know 107 percent but we're going to
be like up
you know maybe several hundred percent
you know from that particular low
obviously that's a short-term trading
low but you know this is um i say all
that to say this which is look we were
already in an environment where growth
is trending lower now it's bouncing now
again i've talked about this at nauseum
so i don't need to bring it up here but
it's bouncing now but the trend is lower
in growth and it's very likely that the
trend is lower to a place that's below
below trend below below our potential
growth rate just as a function of all
the tightening we've seen in the economy
already from monetary policy in terms of
rates repricing already from fiscal
policy in terms of not you know uh you
know uh getting the bill back better
program passed and basically returning
back to our normal
fiscal states so
this is an economy that is already weak
and is about to get its knees chopped
off right yeah as a function of this
crude oil energy price spike hey you did
you like this video great we make five
of them a day and post them here on this
channel make sure you subscribe like the
video and see you next time